foreign
disaster causing my anxiety it seems
like my anxiety was causing the Clutter
that stuff was was serving as some kind
of moat around your Castle That was
supposed to protect you from the bad
guys
[Music]
this is John with the Dr John deloney
show
I'm so so grateful you joined us on this
show about your mental and emotional
health and parenting and
marriage and dating and trying to just
figure out what in the world's happened
with our world and more importantly what
we can do about our little path that
we're on
um I I'm just continue to be blown away
by your support and your care so thank
you so much for joining us um if you
want to be on the show give me a buzz
1-844-693-3291
or go to John deloney.com ask either one
of those you're going to leave a message
or write in what's going on and we will
reach back out and get in touch with you
and have you on the show
um and we're getting we got folks
writing and calling in from all over
planet Earth which is just phenomenal so
um wherever you happen to be wherever
you're listening to this or watching
this um so grateful that you're here if
you will take 8.2 seconds of your day
and um just like or subscribe or add or
whatever thing you're doing if you're
watching on YouTube please hit the
Subscribe button it really makes a big
difference for everybody
um and don't forget my new book building
a non-anxious life still in pre-sale I
just I know it's up at this point as
soon as I say that I know you're just
hitting like a little uh 15 second just
pass button I get it totally get it but
also
um it's 20 bucks and we'll offer a bunch
of free stuff with it if you'll go check
it out I'll be really grateful go to
John delaney.com and most importantly
today is Battle of the Bands
at Ramsey Solutions where I work there's
about a thousand 1100 employees here and
everybody comes to Nashville to make it
right to be in the music industry and
then at some point 99.9 of them have to
get jobs and they a lot of them work
here
and so every year the company shuts down
in the afternoon and all of these people
come out of the woods like literally
like there's an admin who's the greatest
singer you've ever heard oh there's a
developer and she's writing code and
I've never seen anybody play guitar like
that
um or Ben comes out he's like the
keyboard rapper sing-along screamo to
the term it's amazing like our drummer
this year was is was on the American
Idol tour of his killer everybody's
everybody's incredible
I don't even know where the bass player
I don't know where Kyle learned to play
like that but he's one of the best of
Everest anyway it's incredible hopefully
by the time this comes out
we're celebrating our championship
trophy that's right and I'd like to see
Ben already has his fingernails painted
black as he should bring back late 90s
early 2000 emo it's not a phase it's a
lifestyle it's a lifestyle
that's what Kelly says about her haircut
but it's all good all right let's go to
Sacramento and talk to the Great and
Powerful Lori what's up Lori
hey Dr Delaney they're taking time
to I don't know if I'm gonna be any help
but I will take time to hang out with
you what's up yeah well I'm really
excited about your new book about
anxiety
um I saw your interview with Don Madsen
from minimal mom about decluttering that
was awesome and that's actually sort of
where all this started so my home's been
cluttered for years I mean boxes piled
high with my mom's clothes her dishes
the kids old toys makeup junk everything
is a mess my kids rooms and their
upstairs bathroom were the only clean
rooms in the house
so I panicked and ended up finding
minimal mom on YouTube and I felt safe
enough to start getting myself out of
this mess
so after about two years I've now got
rid of about eight huge vanloads of
items and with all the support from the
minimum Facebook group and then seeing
your interview and starting to see some
of your inner videos
um like my entire house is basically
minimal like I can't even believe it wow
hey can I just stop I'm gonna say
congratulations like like hoarding or on
the borderline of hoarding or
um as Josh Milburn with the minimalist
calls it uh organiz organizing is just
well planned hoarding right
um getting rid of that stuff is one of
the hardest things to do when you're
talking about mental and emotional
health it's hard it's hard yeah um so
congratulations that's that's not an
easy task um for some people listening
they're like oh my gosh you cleaned your
house wow no no no this is different
this is hard so congratulations way to
go
yeah yeah thank you yeah it wasn't
cleaning my house it was like tearing me
apart just knowing that my kids deserve
a better life and I deserve to be free
of just living in clutter and so my
question is about all the pain and
conflict that came up so like after
cleaning out a room I was supposed to be
happy and peaceful no no no no yes oh
you I was I'm like feeling lost and
angry and Confused yes and what I think
is that instead of the hoarding disaster
causing my anxiety it seems like my
anxiety was causing the Clutter and
recently I'm also thinking like maybe
childhood PTSD or something so yeah so
like how do I deal with all this anxiety
yeah you don't even need to call me you
figured it out so that stuff was was
serving as some kind of moat around your
Castle That was supposed to protect you
from the bad guys yeah
one of those bad guys were old memories
your own nervous system your current
relationships or lack of your Current
financial situation your relationship
with your kids whatever
that just became your thing so instead
of a drink or instead of any number of
of numbing devices you just built a wall
around yourself I would tell you there's
something tragically wrong with your
internal response system if after doing
the decluttering that you have done you
were not sitting in this home with every
anxiety alarm you have ringing off the
hook
because now you're exposed now you have
to deal with whatever was setting those
alarms off in the first place
and so um here's a weird like I think
it's the suckiest thing about anxiety
but I understand the mechanics of it
um when you when your body identifies a
threat so let's say your daughter comes
home and slams the door and doesn't want
to talk to you and you instantly roll
back to when you're a kid and your mom
did that same thing to you
your mom would hold you hostage with her
relationship if you don't make me feel
good then then I'm gonna cut you off
which is like taking oxygen from a child
fast forward your daughter does the same
thing to you or your husband does or
your boyfriend does and your body only
has that one that one road that it knows
to travel and so it sets off all the
alarms and you just start Gathering
stuff around you okay yeah um when that
stuff goes away and you have to just sit
in that
now you got to deal with that actual
relationship
you actually have to grieve it now
here's in the crappy thing about anxiety
is when you avoid when you get some
stuff and make yourself feel a tiny
little bit better your brain goes oh
sweet that works
so the next time she slams the door you
go get more
because your body knows okay this is
going to protect us this keeps us from
having to deal with that keeps us safe
and it builds more and more and more and
so the worst part about anxiety is you
have to go through it that's the only
way that's the only way to heal it's the
only way for the alarms to stop is to go
directly towards them and that's where
you found yourself right you've cleared
all the path and now you're just staring
down at that at the other end of this
thing so I'll flip it on you you tell me
when it comes to choosing Freedom when
it comes to choosing reality when it
comes to the state of your finances
you're reactive your health
what is your body trying to get your
attention and protect you from
well I I think what's happening is that
I'm realizing the mindset that has
started this clutter to begin with like
I've been really
um feeling responsible to take care of
my mom's stuff and to keep her dishes
and recently I had found a lot of her
old artwork she had this really
beautiful porcelain artwork and I talked
to my brother because I felt really
guilty I didn't want to sell it I wanted
to donate it and have somebody
appreciate it and I didn't want my
brother to be upset but he was like you
know mom passed away 20 years ago she
died in 2004 and it's not I felt like
I'm losing my mind it's not like I'm
delusional but like it's been in the
back of my mind thinking about these
little pieces of objects so just objects
and it was running my life and now I'm
just feeling like lost
like now what when when when when are
you gonna let your mom go
see you're cluttering with words now
you're cluttering with thoughts you're
gonna spin it up you're gonna create a
bubble around yourself and I'm not gonna
let you do it at least on this call
you have to sit yeah no I I'm hearing
you you have to sit in it your mom is
not at rest yet because you won't let go
why yeah
um was she great to you was it covering
was it really gnarly growing up wait
what was it
um she was an alcoholic and she had a
mental illness and she would go into
rages she was isolated she was paranoid
she started when I was in my teen she
started drinking really heavily but my
mom was like amazing I mean especially
such a great job it just everything's so
confusing here's what it is I have come
to believe and uh and I might sit down
with a neuroscientist someday or child
psychiatrist they're gonna tell me I'm
crazy
um I don't think I am
if a parent leaves they just disappear
on you they abandon you as a kid that is
tragic on a hundred different levels
starting with neurochemistry and then
ending up in your nervous system and all
the way through
and how it manifests in the real world
I think having a parent who struggles
with addiction is worse and here's why
because they are in the child's home
they are there in body but they are
completely gone
and if a parent leaves a child has to
deal with the reality that there is no
physical presence of my of my safe place
I have to figure another safe place out
but when they're an alcoholic
they're right there
and you ever seen those like old spy
movies where they have that three-prong
hook and they're tied to a rope and
they're trying to throw it over the wall
so they can catch it and they can pull
themselves up that's what kids do every
second of every day trying to connect
with Mom and Dad and if you have a mom
that you were never able to plug into
you have a little girl still asking your
herself over and over again what is so
bad about me I'll try this I'll try this
I'll try this and then she went and died
on you before you got an answer to that
and so you have not let her go
oh yeah I was in my late 30s I was in my
almost 40s when I she passed away that
does I don't care I know it doesn't
matter now you're a little girl yeah
nine-year-old girl is just sprinting on
that treadmill
yeah and you gotta sit down with that
nine-year-old you and say
she didn't drink cause of me
and she loved you the best she could but
she had demons that you will never fully
realize and understand
yeah that's true and you've got to let
Mom go in the present
yeah well the the first steps that I
took were trying to think about it and
the council was like they have no idea
what to do don't think about it
was declutter that was the only thing I
knew how to do and like don't and the
minimum among Facebook group and you and
I just went to all these resources and I
thought the demons are so big I can't
think about them but I can take steps
and get one piece decluttered and that's
my home as I can start there and so in
the video game of your life you have
you've gone through all of the other
stages
and you have now reached the final
dragon
yeah right and that's why I'm calling
you because like now what do I do now
you sit down you sit down tonight
and for the first time I want you to
write your mom a letter actually I
always tell people to write three so you
owe her three
letter number one is how much I miss you
and you have to be very specific almost
reliving in a way remember that time we
remember that time you took me to I miss
you so much and I've had this thing that
I needed you for and you're not here and
I'm so I was heartbroken I miss you
the second letter has to be
truth-telling
here's what you did
here's what I missed
yeah you drank half of my childhood away
and the other half you were so tired or
so exhausted or so mean
and then the third letter has to be and
you can't hedge that by the way you
can't hurt her feelings she's not here
yeah but you have to let yourself
finally feel the truth that you have
never been able to tell yourself because
you hid that truth because you're trying
to get her to love you somehow and it
was never about that
yeah my job was to make sure to glue her
together no my job was to be a little
kid your job is to be a kid
and the third letter is here's what
you're going to miss
here's how excited I am about what comes
next in my life and I just wanted you to
be a part of it just want to let you
know
did you ever have any doubt that she
loved you
well the the amazing thing is when I was
cleaning up her house
drawers
see I had gotten into recovery and I was
trying to talk to her but she was like a
really shut down person like you had to
make appointments to go to her house to
see her and so hold on you realize you
realize that's Madness
yes
yeah
but I I let's move her aside I'm talking
about you the kid
well the the thing that was amazing to
me that finally just it was mind-blowing
I was cleaning out her stuff and I found
a drawer full of Alcoholics Anonymous
literature she had gone to meetings as
scares as she was with people she was
getting clean she's getting sober it was
like wow
and that was because I took the steps I
was the first person in my family to
take the steps to go get clean are you
still sober
oh yeah well it's you know it's really
funny I didn't even do the math since I
was telling my kids yesterday today is
my 30-year clean I've been clean and
sober for 30 years today congratulations
and can I be harsh a little bit and I
mean not harsh but just honestly why not
you were clean from alcohol drugs
whatever for 30 years which is so
incredible I would hug you if you're
standing here
oh yeah I would ask you if I could hug
you and then I would hug you the second
thing is in some ways you just traded
alcohol for
junk
yeah
and so I want you to look at this new
phase as you're getting sober again
okay the 12 steps are incredibly
instructive and I know people roll their
eyes about it they're powerful because
they force you to step back and say this
is bigger than me I gotta have something
bigger than me I gotta believe in
something bigger than me
I've got to have other people I have to
say these things out loud
and you have to go make amends and one
of the the single most important amend
you need to make is to Lori
gotta let that little girl off the hook
yeah
yeah is that fear
yeah absolutely well and I've surrounded
myself with the like you and Don and the
minimal alums like you've been my
support group I know but I know but
we're imaginary Facebook Facebook
we're imaginary
we're not real
Dawn I mean I've developed relationships
with the women on the Facebook group I
know but they're not real
they're on Facebook
they're not real they are real Dawn's my
friend Don and I have like sat and she's
helped me personally with some
challenges Dawn is my friend I've got
her cell phone number
but Dawn and I for you are images on a
screen
those Facebook women sending me a lot of
here's your next step though you've got
to make personal relationships with
people in your world
you've got a little girl that says I'm
not worth being loved or being around
otherwise for God's sakes my mom would
have showed up
and so when you're around people your
body goes to war because people are not
safe
because person number one that's
supposed to always be there wasn't she
was in a bottle
and so how is Laurie
gonna hook be friends with
Susan who lives next door Susan's like a
banker and on the other side is Dan and
he's just weird and his cars are funny
like that's where you have to go because
your your body cannot go to rest
until it has people in the real world in
real proximity
it would be failing you if you if it let
you sleep at night
it would be failing I had a
oh yeah go ahead
it's job is to keep you spun up and
anxious right now because it knows we
are not safe because we cannot do Life
by ourselves
and Facebook is a good Pro a good
approximation but it's not real
yeah I've had a support group of women
um since 1997 and we get together once a
month and we're in each other's lives
um what's that 25 years so yeah so now
I'm kind of starting to get this whole
new like the decluttering thing and kind
of starting to reach out and kind of
getting these new groups okay so that's
good yeah my my women's support group is
amazed and they've been holding my hand
with me like every step of the way and
now I'm kind of getting these new
Facebook friends and the thing I love
about them is they know what I'm talking
about my women's friends love me but
they're like wow we don't know and the
women on the group and like I'm starting
to get people who understand this whole
um piece of my life that's just opened
up in this last two years so now I'm
starting to get those okay so here's
here's Branch out here's next step I
want you to write those three letters
and it's gonna take a couple of days I
want you to spend letter one
it's been a day or two letter two it's
been a day or two letter three spin a
day or two and then I want you to call
the women the real life women
into your home
your new clean decluttered home and
they'll all be amazed give them a tour
let that sink in how proud of of you
they're gonna be
I want you to feel that don't deflect it
oh no it's because of dawn it's because
no no no we're just people on pod you
did the work
and then I want you to read the letters
to them out loud in person
let them sit in a circle around you I
want you to feel that room
let your body feel that room let your
body feel we are not alone as David
Kessler says grief Demands a witness
we're going to grieve in front of our
friends
at some point not before but maybe after
you post those letters to your Facebook
community
and they are going to be your community
that walks alongside you that says okay
now that we're here you got to go see a
trauma counselor you got to deal with
that you've got to start going to
Al-Anon meetings
you've got to sit down and do some
Bodywork or say MDR or you got to do
some heavy duty stuff to let your body
be at peace with letting your mom go
and the things that you've had to make
peace with relationally with your kids
or your friends that you've heard over
the year you're going to make peace with
that
but that is not done by yourself just
thinking about it can't cannot be done
thinking about it
it's got to be done in reality with your
body
I'm really I mean to tell you I'm proud
of you is like the understatement of the
year I don't have the words for it you
inspire me I got a lot of decluttering I
got to do at my house in fact Don and I
have talked extensively about it
um and by the way for everyone who's
listening if you struggle with that
stuff Don Madsen is amazing
um you can check out her stuff uh Josh
Fields Milburn and TK Coleman and Ryan
Nicodemus with the minimalist they're
incredible too they're also great
friends
really great folks in in Walking you
through the decluttering process they've
got some some plans on how to do it at
my house is just so overwhelming
um they're really remarkable
hang on the line Lord I'm going to send
you a copy of my brand new book on me
I'm just for free and uh uh Jenna will
get a sent to you I'm proud of you I'm
proud of you do those three things tell
your friends and then holler back girl
at me and you're supposed to say I ain't
no hollaback girl but holler back and
then I want to see how I want to let
everybody know who listens to the show
how you're doing I'm proud of you it's
awesome we'll be right back
hey good folks deloni here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time those become healthy habits
they almost become automatic like
choosing to slow down and make time for
a daily practice of prayer and
meditation one thing that has helped me
with my daily practice is hallow hallow
is the number one Prayer app in the
world and they're giving you three free
months to get started that's three
months for free to prioritize your
mental and spiritual health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music through guided prayers
meditation and more and by the way
hallow isn't just Catholic you can
tailor the content towards your faith
tradition or if you don't have a faith
tradition it's a great place to start
from scripture readings to prayers to
journaling hallow makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember hallow is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hallow.com deloney today to start your
free trial just follow the simple
prompts at hollow.com deloney for 90
days free
all right we're back let's go to Justin
in Colorado Springs what's up J Money
how we doing
hey thank you for having me of course
what's up
um well I'm I've got a kind of a life
decision I need to make that's causing
me a lot of anxiety my oldest child is
showing early signs of depression that
I'm really concerned will eventually
escalate to something life-threatening
um we think that moving a couple hours
North near family and cousins that he
has a close relationship will help a lot
but I'm in this anxious situation where
it doesn't matter if I decide to move or
to stay I I have so much anxiety that I
can't seem to function I've lost 15
pounds in three weeks and I've I've
taken a few days off of works because I
just couldn't get myself to work
and I'm not sure what to do
before you do anything else
you have to commit to go getting Justin
well
because you're not
and you haven't been for a long time
have you
uh no it's been a long road it's been a
long time
I I am very hesitant to tell you what
I'm about to tell you okay because it's
not always causal
and I have no intention of heaping guilt
or anything like that on you are you in
a place where I can be super honest with
you
yeah how old's your kid
he is 15. tell me about this stuff he's
experiencing because you hinted at he's
he's on the path to to Dying by Suicide
so like walk me through where he is at
where he's come what's kind of the
origin story here
uh so that uh go back in time last year
he was in eighth grade uh middle school
he uh about the the into the end of the
first quarter of this school year
um he he kind of we've noticed that his
grades started slipping and they took a
very steep trajectory down to to just
not passing in just about all of his
grades
um we we talked to him and he was very
complacent he didn't he didn't really
care
um when he has a lot of work to do he
gets overwhelmed and and like for
example on a Saturday he was doing a
math worksheet that was just front and
back maybe 16 questions and he was
working on it for six hours
um but it took him that long because he
was just Frozen
uh he couldn't couldn't handle it and we
we eventually we got some help we got
him a life coach we've we started having
very strict consequences for not getting
homework done and he has eventually
gotten himself together he has had he's
gotten good grades
um and that's because we're on him all
the time he doesn't take responsibility
for it he he doesn't
um
he's still in that state if we were to
let up he would go back to it you know I
I just got to jump in here is that okay
this is a hard conversation to have
because we're not in person I don't like
having this over the phone okay I just
need to say that out for up front
because if you could see my body
language it's going to be very different
than what you're going to experience on
the phone okay
but you literally just called me
explaining how you are paralyzed and
Frozen with a decision to make
and my guess is that's been the course
of action
and so in many ways
your son is just simply
operating with the set of operating
instructions he's had in front of him
his whole life
and you're exactly right when I find
found out
that straight A's can be a trauma
response to
I was set free
because that's how I've handled it I
don't have two phds because I'm not
smart I have it because I was that
broken and insecure that I kept chasing
and chasing something so that somebody
would tell me I had value
and so
the question here isn't life coach and
you stupid lazy little boy and I can't
freaking believe you
the response is sitting on the bed with
him and saying bro me too
my whole life me too
we've tried to help in a very loving way
it hasn't been like you're stupid I know
I know I know I know
but he'll hear you
but more importantly than hear you he'll
watch you and he will feel you
and that's why I tell you before
anything here I mean obviously he's got
to make his bed he's got to turn his
grades in he's got to turn his stuff in
I'm not saying for a not accountable
home
but I'm going to tell you my home
changed some of these problems that I
was reading books about and calling my
colleagues all across the country some
of the best experts in the world on some
of these problems
evaporated when I went and did the
counseling work that I needed to do
that is not true for everybody that's
why I don't like saying it because it's
not cause I can't point every kid who's
struggling with depression in the world
because their parents are have whatever
but the way you're laying this out for
me
sounds very similar
how long have you struggled with this
how long have you wrestled with things
being kind of low just kind of dysthymic
kind of anxious
uh it's
been forever oh we've been married 16
years and it's definitely been for all
of that
where did you pick that up where did
where did you pick up that you were only
as good as your report card
um
I think I picked it up from my own
childhood we always had the standard
that
um we we don't fail in school we don't
do that we work hard
um in my childhood our parents divorced
and it was a fairly ugly divorce
um no abuse but emotional so emotionally
not I'm gonna just invent a map here
that you and I would have to spend weeks
together to fully flesh out but here's a
here's a story I can make up real quick
there's a nasty gnarly divorce and by
the way I want to take apart I want to
separate
we don't fail from we work really hard
that that ideal has got us where we are
as a culture because we have a whole
bunch of people that are terrified and
puckered up to fail which means nobody's
going all in
because everything's about the grade at
the piece of paper not about the effort
and the let's just go solve this problem
and we're going to make some mistakes
along the way companies that celebrate
failure do better than companies that
celebrate how shiny the exterior of the
building is
so I'm gonna imagine you as a
nine-year-old little kid or a
seven-year-old little kid who had one
job and that was to figure out how you
could fix mom and dad
and the way you kept every adult in your
life happy was getting a grade
and suddenly you outsourced your sense
of well-being by a performance standard
a scorecard and then that scorecard
becomes your child and if your child
behaves and your child does well then
you are doing good and if your child
drops the ball in the Little League game
and your child doesn't get grades acts
and your child falls off a map then
you're failing as a parent that's your
grade is an f and you will work really
hard
is that ring a bell I'm just making that
up does that ring a bell
yeah I was I was also always the
Peacekeeper in the home as a kid that's
right
yeah
at some point you have to go do the
scary terrifying and I've been there
it's hard work of sitting with a
counselor
and asking yourself and walking through
with somebody
oh man it wasn't me that was so
unlovable this whole time
because what you're what you as a guy
who's worked with adolescents my entire
career
when you told me about your son's
performance falling up a map I instantly
went to one of a few things he found
drugs
he is his body is shutting itself down
because he cannot keep up with this
performance standard he doesn't have he
doesn't have a he doesn't know how to
make you happy
or number three he is disconnected
completely unplugged he has no one to
plug into
I would say it's number three I don't
think that we have such high standards
that he's just overwhelmed by it I think
that no no not standards not standards
let me say it um
my expectation for my kid my son
my expectation for him
is that he worked really hard with the
machinery and the wiring and the
resources he was just dropped into
planet Earth with
and he happened to have won the cosmic
Lottery and he was born to two parents
who are still married who love each
other who work really hard who treat
each other with respect and who both
have multiple graduate degrees
and one of his parents was an expert in
teaching kids how to develop cognitively
and then he ended up with another parent
that was an expert in taking adolescence
through
and so I've got very high excellent
standards because of
so I could care less about his grades
but he's going to work really hard and I
know if he works really hard the grades
will more than take care of themselves
yeah
but that's different than you will get
an A
and all of that has to be anchored into
I love you so much
I'm with you
and most of that has come from me
sitting taking him to breakfast once a
week for the last few years saying dude
when I was your age I screwed this up
here
and here's what I did at work the other
day that I wish I could have back
does that make sense and so whether you
move or not what what how do you think
this move is going to solve all of this
um he doesn't have any friends he's very
close to his cousins and the move would
put him in the same school with his
cousins uh it would help him with some
social skills and and the school is
significantly better it's a smaller
school it's highly rated it's it I think
it'd be a good good fit for him so I
think it would help him with the social
aspect but you don't want to do this or
you can't do this why
uh I I think it's because
uh of of some of my own struggles in the
past
uh we moved to our current area because
we noticed that every time we moved for
a job and by the way it took me 10 years
to get into a career I failed out of
college several times but I eventually
did graduate and I work as a software
engineer now
um
but we noticed every time we moved our
mortgage would get more expenses our
living expenses would go up and so we
decided we're going to buy a house that
we're comfortable in a good area and
we're gonna raise our kids the rest of
their lives in this area
um I not only that but I felt
comfortable here I feel like the house
was comfortable I feel like our life was
comfortable my career was comfortable so
I spent the last 10 15 years being
Frozen in fear a lot of times and unable
to provide for my family not unable to
provide but struggle to provide
and and I feel like this move is going
to upend all of that like like for
example moving up a couple hours up
north is going to cause like a 40
increase in our mortgage and we're going
to be right back into that financially
unstable situation again and all here's
it all this tells me that you're not
okay
what you've done is you've created an
entire life around avoidance
yeah I am all about if you have an
opportunity your kids getting bullied
your kid is in a toxic school which
those do exist and you have the
opportunity to move them to a safer
Place great
you have the opportunity to move them
over into another school or whatever
that's I'm all about that that's fine
millions millions of people don't have
that option but that's great but what
you're going to do is you're going to
continue to reinforce that out there
somewhere is where everything is okay
and that's not where healing from
anxiety comes that's not where healing
from depression comes that's not where
any sort of relational healing comes
from none of that is extrinsic
that's not true if you're being abused
or you're an abject poverty
or you're being bullied on a daily basis
yes a change of environment is powerful
and huge and important
but you haven't healed you've just
created some a place where you can
bubble wrap yourself
where I'm currently at yes I yeah
I'm assuming you've been to counseling
and done all that stuff for years
uh
no this thing anxiety got so bad that I
finally did just in the last month or so
and and his first feedback was I
probably have chronic depression yeah
that's what it sounds like but there's
no way I'm gonna diagnose you on this
thing but
um sounds like you've got some
significant work to do
let me tell you this on the other side
okay can I give you like just like I
want to shine a Big Bright Light Of Hope
okay
all right
I'm a mess
in all the best kind of ways I hope
Kelly right now is waving her hand at me
like I am I'm a lot to work with and I
know that okay
but
on most days not all of them most days I
just fall asleep when I get home because
I'm tired
and on most days not all days
my kids come tackle me when I walk in
the door
and on most days my wife and I's
marriage is pretty good not always we
have seasons when it's tough we get off
track and we have to like walk back on
the track again
but I'm a hundred percent confident that
if my boss came in tomorrow and just
said show's over you're fired
man I would be low I would be sad
because I like this I like being able to
sit with people and I like all the
people I get to work with
and then in a few weeks it would be on
to the next
and I'd be sad and I'd be angry but I
wouldn't be anxious and I wouldn't fall
off a cliff with into a black hole again
you see the difference
yeah
but that has only come from a bunch of
hard hard work with a therapist
and a bunch of hard work with how I move
and how I eat and all that stuff that I
didn't want to deal with but it's
reality
sounds like you have good confidence
that you could recover and I I don't
know that I have that confidence that's
right and I I promise you I promise you
I did not have that before we started
this adventure
and so I the reason I'm telling you the
hope is there
I'm on the other side of it
actually I'm not on the other side of it
every day I'm just making some choices
it's like having bad breath man I brush
my teeth twice a day so I don't have bad
breath it'll come back in two days if I
don't deal with it
and what you've got to do is get those
those skills deal with this stuff in the
past let your body rest finally and then
begin to just build it out
whenever somebody tells me that their
kid is struggling inside their own home
my question is always how's your
marriage my question is always how are
your finances and your stress and your
home how how are you
because so often not always but so often
our kids take their cues from us
and I love you enough to tell you
you got to go do that hard work
so wherever you end up moving by the way
I think a 40 I wouldn't I wouldn't buy a
house then maybe for the next few years
you rent
and if that makes your heart start
racing I can't breathe and then we're
gonna go deal with that we're gonna head
straight into that storm
but if your counselor immediately
identified whoa you've been carrying
some bricks for a long time brother and
your body has been running low for a
long time let's go straight into that
let's jump straight into that and let's
be really honest and vulnerable with our
son hey son I've been dealing with
chronic anxiety for years and I didn't
even know it
and I think you've picked that up from
me
and we have some very special attributes
that the rest of the community doesn't
have and our bodies are pretty sensitive
to the signals in our world I'm getting
after it I'm gonna work on it I hope
you'll come with me
you gotta make your bed and you still
got to turn your homework in still gonna
hold you accountable
but we've got a hard path ahead of us
and I'm going first
and when your kid has a ringside seat
too oh that's what a dad going on a
healing Adventure looks like and you
give them a road map and he's not may
not follow you right away
but I'll always know I know I know the
path I know a path out of here
we know a path out of here because my
old man took that first step and on the
line I'm gonna send you building a
non-anxious life new books is going to
give you a path and I'm also going to
hook you up with six months of better
help for free I know you're in a
therapist at home but I want you to have
an option that you can call you can text
that you have somebody else that you can
reach out to please
continue seeing that counselor and do
the hard work you're worth it
your whole household is worth it
figure out the move later
let's start getting well now we'll be
right back
hey good folks Dr John deloney here can
we all just take a minute to take a deep
breath
there's a lot going on especially in the
economy you're hearing words like
recession continued inflation thrown
around and it's making your stress
levels Spike I don't care who you are
but remember we've been through Seasons
like this before and the best thing you
can do is focus on controlling what you
can control you can control your
spending and saving you can you can
control your daily habits you can
and you can control making time for
sleep and this one is easy to forget
especially when you're stressed but
sleep is key to taking care of your
physical and mental health and I found
that the key to good sleep starts with
an incredible mattress and that's why I
love dream Cloud mattresses they're
incredibly comfortable and right now
dream cloud is making it easy to invest
in good sleep with their biggest offer
yet 40 off all mattresses plus an
additional fifty dollars in savings
exclusively for my listeners go to
dreamcloudsleep.com deloney or
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
John deloney to get your new mattress
and start sleeping today
all right what's up we're back let's go
to Washington DC where everything is
thought through and calm and peaceful
and talk to Christine what's up
Christine
hi thank you so much for having me on of
course what's up
okay so just quick rundown I guess um
I'm 23 my boyfriend is 25. uh we've been
dating for a little over six months now
um we're both pretty sure that this is
it going really well
I love it I'm already sure all right
I've been married for 21 years and my
wife said something the other day and I
looked at her and I was like I don't
know you but if you haven't figured out
in six months good for you good for you
all right so so what's up we're giving
the time we're giving it time but um
you're 22. 23 how old are you 1.23 23
it's a big difference Jenna how does
that how does the Taylor Swift song go
that's what I was getting all confused
Christine all right so you're 23 he's 25
y'all have figured it out yeah you know
no problems ahead of us
none okay so what's up
um so it's going great family loves him
my friends love him and I know this like
issue doesn't have to do with him
but the issue I've been running into is
with my like group of girlfriends that
I've had since like childhood were like
best friends we do everything together
um have you know like keep in touch over
texts call I see them a lot
um
but in the last like two months two of
them have like separately and now like
together
um have kind of come up to me and said
that they think I'm spending too much
time with my boyfriend and that they
feel that I'm not prioritizing
prioritizing them as much as I should
hold on
all right keep going this is awesome
keep going okay
because I can
I get done and I know that's not true
and here's why okay you you get to
decide what your relational priorities
are
yeah
and if
you have found the one
it just makes sense
yeah right yeah and I'll tell you
you will have some friends that are so
freaking excited for you
yeah watching their friend be in love
and be gross and silly and I don't want
to wait like all Dustin's creaked out
like that's so like and awesome so great
and then you can have a couple of old
friends
who the way they want their life to go
is now disrupted because somebody else
has found love and joy and different
relationship priorities
yeah and instead of looking in the
mirror they start throwing grenades
yeah and you're about to experience if
you're not already what I think was the
most heartbreaking thing that I didn't
know about I wasn't prepared for
actually the most heartbreaking thing I
wasn't prepared for was getting married
but second to that second to that was
like
I can't put into words the friendships I
had as an elementary school kid and as a
high school kid
yeah Brothers is all I can is the best I
mean I'm talking about guys who lay down
in traffic for me and vice versa yeah
yeah and I was unprepared for turning 23
and 25 and 28.
when one guy makes a decision like dude
I'm not hanging out with you if that's
how you're gonna roll
when yeah somebody gets in a bad car
wreck and everything shifts and one guy
moves away when I went to grad school
when somebody else gets fired from their
job somebody else gets married another
person gets married this one as a kid I
was unprepared for how lost I was when
my brother started Living their own
lives
I was really dumbfounded when my bestest
best friends in when I was in my 30s
when we all started having kids and it
was amazing at first and then one of
them turned out to be a Cub Scout dad
then the other one turned into be like a
little league Dad where he would like
doodle literally plays on his work pad
next to his phone and then I was like uh
let's go like on adventures dad and
they're like it's hot we're not going
out so I started realizing oh we're just
this is the part where we shift again
yeah and so you just have to do the hard
work with a few people that are gonna
root for you when things are great for
you
and that will hold you accountable now
if they were calling and saying hey we
think this guy's not a good guy
and that's yeah that's
yeah that's not when you're with him you
are we see our friend who we love
sacrificing her soul to be with this guy
that's a different thing because they've
earned the right to speak into that but
if it's just like you should be with us
more
and they start singing Avril Lavigne
lyrics to you it's time just to as the
great Jay-Z said dust your shoulders off
and I know that sounds callous okay so I
threw a lot at you what do you think
yeah I
yeah it's hard I know
um
I just I think my biggest thing is I
just I feel so guilty about it and it's
gotten to a point where like if I ever
choose hanging out like going out to
dinner with my boyfriend instead of
going out for drinks with my girlfriends
I I feel guilty about it even though I'm
I'm so joyful when I'm with him and like
at peace I don't know I I guess
how do I not feel so guilty about it
even though I know I'm I'm doing the
right thing I don't think that's that
just takes time I would tell you choose
guilt over resentment every single time
because if you choose to not hang out
with the person you want to be with and
the person that you have more fun with
and the person that yeah looks at you
and is like you're my girl forever like
all that back of the tailgate country
song stuff if you choose to not be with
him to go sit until the same High School
Stories and have the same drinks and the
same oh my gosh
you're gonna start to resent those women
yeah you're gonna hate it when they text
you yeah yeah and so choose guilt over
resentment you love them enough to not
let them drag you underwater into hate
yeah yeah the second thing is here's a
an important way I've shifted the way I
experience guilt in the world especially
when it comes to relationship stuff
and this is a hundred percent true
across the board
you can only show up for your friends if
you're whole
yeah if you're not okay hanging out with
your friends is you are not loving them
yeah right so you've got to be whole
and if you continue so when I say my
boundaries out loud the things that keep
me whole hey guys I don't drink anymore
hey guys I found out and it's
embarrassing that if I have gluten I
have a rocket diarrhea for like five
days and so like whatever it is you're
gonna have all your buddies they're good
they're supposed to make fun of you
that's their job like oh this guy can't
eat any food
um and that's fine that's that's just me
being a grown-up and thinking it's funny
and they've got their things
but there's always that one friend
that's like are you freaking kidding me
and they'll bring gluten stuff
everywhere and just shut up on you right
or every time you go to the oh you're
going to the gym oh my God and I just
want to shut up
at some point
they are choosing to not be in a
relationship with me not the other way
around
yeah and that's heartbreaking
so the Heartbreak that you're
experiencing I want you to flip it
around you aren't feeling guilty
because you have found somebody that you
care about and you love and you actually
just like hanging out with them more
than the other people
which is a hundred percent normal by the
way
in that in that scenario you are the bad
guy and you're guilty for choosing A
over B in the other scenario
your friends are choosing to be selfish
over watching their friend fall in love
and be have so much joy
they are choosing to not be in a
relationship with you so instead of
those feelings being guilt those
feelings are sadness and heartbreak
because you thought you thought those
girls loved you more than that
and they don't they love themselves
those women are about them not you
and that is a heartbreak you got to sit
with that's that stings right
yeah but they are opting out of
relationship with you because they want
their picture more than they want your
joy and happiness
and I hate that for you yeah but I'm
also glad you found the one
it makes everything perfect
so it doesn't has he farted in front of
you yet
um
I don't know if he has oh you would know
that means y'all haven't got there yet
six months in So Perfect you aren't even
close but awesome but awesome
yeah
um
you're not broken there's not something
wrong with you
yeah I think that helps I it's just I
guess it's just kind of new territory
for me and figuring out like I don't
know I just I just so enjoyed being with
him and it feels weird that I prefer
that over my friends now and I love love
um my friend George Campbell just had a
baby this morning are we allowed to
announce it yeah yeah it'll be out there
by the time it's out
yeah it'll be out uh by the time the
show airs and the message I sent him was
everything in your life just changed
because you didn't know you didn't know
and yeah when my buddies like dude I
think I'm gonna ask this girl to marry
me and then they called and like she
said yes and I would always tell her
everything just changed
yeah love makes you realize the things
that you thought were important ah
weren't that important love helps you
sift through those other relationships
and a few will make it through because
they will be all about loving you and
this new knucklehead you've decided to
be with and if y'all break up in two
months those women who were so excited
for you will be the ones that come over
to your house with nachos in sadness and
just sit with you and light candles and
talk bad about them and sprinkle you
with essential oils and thieves and
whatever like they'll do all that stuff
right and the other girls will say I
told you so
yeah that was kind of accurate yeah and
you don't want those women in your life
they're opting out they're opting out
you are good to go you're good to go
Christine I'm proud of you
and I like as I I'm such a sucker for a
love story I love it when people fall in
love so I'm really excited for you
that's fun even if it doesn't work out
long term because you're still basically
a child it's still pretty awesome and
I'm excited for you I do hate it that
your friends are opting out
but
I hate to say this this will be the rest
of your life you'll get a job somewhere
that you're excited about and two people
will opt out and you'll have two kids
and somebody will opt out or you'll
choose to have no kids and people will
opt out
and I think the great challenge of our
life isn't to run around and make sure
everybody is okay that we're making sure
that their world is good at our expense
I think it is sitting in that sadness
and heartbreak when people choose to opt
out of relationship with us
oh because that hurts you're awesome
Christine
uh I'm trying to think of a good 80s
metal song but those all ended pretty
tragically so Go Get It Go Get Married
is there hey Jenna is there is there a
Taylor Swift song about young love
I was gonna say dear John but that was
not a good song right sweet nothing
Sweet Nothing Christine listen to that
song I don't know is that is that good
sure sure all right we'll be right back
hey what's up Dr John deloney here check
it out my new book building a
non-anxious life is now available for
pre-order here's the great news anxiety
is not the enemy we've been led to
believe I know this because I've walked
alongside countless folks over the last
two decades and I've struggled with this
too if you create a life of
intentionally living out the six daily
choices I've outlined in this book
you're gonna be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you you're
going to learn the choices you can make
day by day to create a more peaceful
joyful less chronically stressed
non-anxious life plus when you pre-order
my book I want to give you something to
help you today that's why you'll
instantly get my newest talk smoke fire
and freedom that I gave to several
thousand folks a few months ago where I
break down the misunderstandings and
myths we believe about anxiety how to
reclaim your freedom and how to build a
non-anxious life so pre-order building a
non-interest life today for just 20
bucks at John deloney.com
all right as we wrap up today's show um
back in the early 2000s there was this
band called My Chemical Romance
and they wrote a song called Welcome to
the Black Parade
it was fine
it's fine it was this Gothic Anthem
about loss and love and you can do it
and sad poetry about our dads and all
that
but then in 2023
a band was born by the name of my weekly
low
which was kind of making fun of our
weekly report tool here at the office
and that man took the song Welcome to
the Black Parade
and gave it the appropriate treatment
to where now children run out of the
auditorium
to go repair their relationships with
their friends and family people have
already created like nuclear reactors
and stuff after we've performed it
this is like Bill and Ted's too I think
we're gonna align the planets
China's gonna call and be like hey guys
are bad are bad let's be friends north
of South Korea will make amends Russia
is going to call Ukraine and be like
guys we've lost it let's let's come back
together they're gonna get sacks of
McDonald's cheeseburgers and just we're
gonna figure this out our cover of this
song will solve world peace I I have no
doubt
and even though we play it exactly the
same and the lyrics are exactly the same
I think that it's going to come through
better oh yeah with our version I think
they sold what 40 million copies of this
but it's going to be our rendition in
front of a few of our work colleagues
y'all heard it here first everybody on
the greatest show of all time
Welcome to the Black Parade it goes like
this
when I was a young boy my father took me
to the city to see a marching band he
said son when you grow up will you be
the savior of the broken
the beaten and the damned he said will
you defeat them your demons and all the
non-believers the planes they've made
because one day I'll leave you a phantom
to lead you in the summer to join the
Black Parade
and sometimes I get the feeling she's
watching over me and other times I feel
like I should go and through it all the
rise and fall the bodies in the streets
and when you're gone we want you all to
know we'll carry on
and though your dead and God believe me
your memory will carry on
my heart I can't contain it
it's a lifestyle
no wait what is it's not a lifestyle to
what
it's not a phase it's a lifestyle it's a
lifestyle
paint your fingernails black America
Welcome to the Black Parade I love you
guys stay in school Under drug spot
[Music]